今日はそろそろ髪の毛を切りたいはじめしたそうです
すまねえみんな最近実はとてつもなく忙しく
ね中部さんなら長はいいかがシックわけじゃないんですけれども
何だろうなちょっとやることが多いですよ今週頑張ればな異臭がちょっと楽になるけど
もうその先には god 忙しいことが待ってるよね
ちょっと今
ただいただければ勝負の時なんですよなんてねちょっと
無力ないろいろ大変で頑張るけど見たのだろうなぁ
これはもうずっと前から買ってやりたいと思ってたんですけども源氏がなくてできませ
んでした
jrx マイクロドライブジョイのスタントラジコンですくれ中スタンドアクションで
銃を無事走りば悪いね
軍票みたよねこれ動かしたい理由なんですよってしたかったんですけどもうちょっと
電磁が出たに選んでショパン8日ティってきたんでもう積んできますこんなこんな感じ
さあ本難しいやつだ来たぞ来た来た来たぴターン電池は合計6個も出るらしいです
はあああ俺マジなドライビングスクールパターライディングスクールのドライビング
スクール撮ってみます
はい
長いろーしーぼびー2
頭痛マジでドライバー預けるの面倒を置く採用
とついて毎回ドライバー使わないといけないと桜
俺がまじでまじでまじでまじでメンドくせー
マジでドライバーがない世界の平和を祈るよ
2そして俺いつものようにドライパーツカーでいつものように二電池開けへよ
でもねすぐには通れないよこれ
硬くねちょっと開けずがいいかもねー
トゥルルルル今開けてる8 c フォニー
なないろちポニーとぅるルームを打って true でてだあきたきたきたきたきた
日向じゃあな事故
方はいいんだけどもどこに開けずらいのあるんですよね
ドライバーねマジでね多分で人生で一番大事なことだと思ったらこれた無盡頭に何持っ
てきますからねれたらまずドライバーと間違えないことありますからねさあお渡しまし
たでもこれでつくだろうと思います
よし行くぞ
ben あれ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
car
me
うわぁ始めないんでしょねぇねぇ
あああああ
ああああああ
まぁなんと受けなきゃいけです
ダメなんですけどもあれだけの機動力があれば階段からでもコースターとかご検討と
までこれると思いますいきます
こいよ
ああああああ
def
ん
持っています